[Music] Please welcome Chief Technology and
Product Officer at Lumen, Dave Ward. [Music] Hey
everyone, I am the last speaker before launch
and my name is Dave Ward and as you just heard
I'm the chief technology and product officer
at Lumen. Um what that means after we've seen
peaked through the keyhole of so many industries
is that I'm going to show you uh what's going on
in the world of telecommunications uh lumin as a
service provider and I admit I'm a bit flinger I
uh I think about passing packets and photons
there has to be somebody that does that. So so
that's me. So, Lumen, we call ourselves and refer
to ourselves as the trusted network for AI. And
what's really fascinating for me thinking about
the connectivity portion of what we heard this
morning for an AI strategy, you obviously need
to choose an AR partner. We're at a palenture
conference. We have something in common. Um, mo
almost all the use cases were getting access to
lock data and understanding the relationships
of that data. So for an AI strategy, you need
uh to choose an AI partner, you need to have a
cloud strategy, but frequently what's not talked
about at all is that connectivity and moving that
data to feed the platform, to feed the LLMs. And
on average, what we're seeing from our enterprise
customers is on the order of 36 different data
sources. Our company's no different. Your
company's probably uh very similar. The data
is locked on prem. The data is in data centers.
The data is in hyperscalers. The data is in SAS
platforms. To get to unlock that data, you have
to be able to connect it all together. And so the
transformation going on in the service provider
world is around of course this AI revolution.
Many things that um perhaps you've been reading in
the in the industry are around the growth of data
centers and the gigawatt data centers that are
being built as was said earlier today for an AI
for AI infrastructure you have to have the power
infrastructure you have to have the water the real
estate and also you have to have the connectivity
infrastructure so to put it into perspective there
we have about 240 million square feet of data
centers in the US today By the end of 2028,
we're going to have about a billion square feet
of data center space. And so just the fundamental
amount of money going into AI and going to these
data centers leads me to to describe one of our
one of our first businesses, which is backbone
business. Uh Lumen um has the largest amount of
conduit, the largest amount of fiber in the lower
48. And we recently announced $8.5 uh billion
dollars of new contracts with hyperscalers and
data centers to interconnect the new AI regions.
And so we're focusing a lot of our business on
building that backbone for for for AI. Also,
we are an enterprise services company. And so as
I've heard so many of the talks today, it's and
and what I'm going to show in my presentation in
the examples, the fundamental question is how can
enterprises join the AI economy? How can they get
access to that data? How can they rebuild the comm
the telecommunication services that are necessary
to transform their own companies to to be relevant
and to take advantage of the AI economy? So we
build metro fiber, inner city fiber, connection
to data centers, connection to the hyperscalers.
We're the uh largest by means of traffic internet
service provider in America and the world in fact
and so bigger and better internet. But there's
a couple things just talking about history and
the transformation. Took about 30 years to get
from some of the early concepts of the internet
to widely deployed about 25 years ago. It took
about 15 years to get to cloud 1.0. And that's
the cloud economy that we know today. But what I
just mentioned is that with basically four times
the amount of AI data centers being built in the
next three years, it's a fundamentally different
transformation speed that has to happen for all
of us in this room and certainly for me in our
company. So cloud scale and what I mean by scale
to to really simplify this it takes over a 100
gig link about a day to move a pabyte. Okay,
puts it in perspective. So therefore a lot
feeding the data for LLMs is frequently talked
about in exabytes. That's a thousand pabytes.
Unacceptable to use that level of speed. So,
we're building a new network as I just mentioned
and really bringing in new on-ramps to the cloud,
new on-ramps to data centers and moving from 100
gig to 400 gig to 800 gig to 1.6 terab as a basic
connectivity directly to enterprises and of course
um as new on-ramps and hyperscalers and and data
centers. So, that's the physical aspect of it. The
next aspect is we're transforming the traditional
tele uh telecommunications business as we've
heard from so many companies today from being
paperdriven to being a digital experience. I want
to connect from X to Y. I want to hit a button. I
want to go now or I want to use APIs to get that
done. And so that digital layer is a fundamental
transformation of the customer experience that
we want to bring uh into the market. What you
can see in this map is what I deal with every day.
And what I mean by that is a telephone network.
Many folks know they see the big windowless brick
buildings in their metropolitan area. Telephones
uh central office that was built over the last
120 years or so of every single copper line for
every telephone brought to a central location.
Perhaps there's some wiring centers, often tens
if not hundreds in each metropolitan area. How
does the copper lines or the legacy network that
was built over the last 30 years be relevant
in the AI economy? It's really not. Um, we're
highly regulated industry. We have to handle 911
services. We're a critical infrastructure for the
nation and for all of the industries here. So I
I'm working to transform not only my industry but
enable enterprises to be able to transform their c
their companies by changing the access technology
and the speed that has been the foundation of how
companies have gotten to where they are today. So
that leads me to uh my first example. We partner
deeply with Palunteer because Lumen historically
although you may not necessarily recognize the
name you may recognize that we are an accumulation
of acquisitions. You may know Centry Link, Level
3, Quest, Savis, TWW Telecom, Wiltel etc. These
all form the company that is Lumen. I've been
there about a year and a half and brought in
not only to change the network architecture but
to change the backend architecture because as I
arrived like many companies here who are created
through acquisition nothing gets turned off all
the data silos exist all the inventory systems
exist and it's that unlocking the data and forming
a relationship that really is my first example of
how we take out our legacy equipment and take out
our legacy architecture And to do that we needed
to not only transform that network architecture
but in particular transform the workflows in the
operational environment to get that done. It was
driven by paper. You know that you see the the
people driving around in trucks and doing telecom
work and things like that. Telecommunications was
a completely ticketdriven industry. And so what
what you're highlighting what I'm is highlighting
in here in this in this uh in this demo video was
what it looks like in a metropolitan area
for a central office and then the wiring
centers around it and how the connectivity
of enterprises is connected there. And so
we needed to be able to go into those inventory
systems fully deconstruct customer line devices
connected to in which wiring center and deploy
technicians to be able to take that equipment out
like and transform how that network is going
to be built. Like a lot of enterprises here,
that transformation particularly of a physical
uh of physical assets based company like we are
and so many that presented earlier than me, we
actually have to transform the hardware. I mean,
we're talking about the copper lines going down
the poles. We're talking about the fiber in the
ground. We're talking about those buildings and
what's in them. And of course, like like everyone
in a transformation, we're setting targets for how
much cost can we take out? And for me the the cost
we want to take out is of the legacy equipment and
the legacy systems and architecture that uh is one
old but two preventing enterprises and customers
from getting into the AI economy. So to do that
we partnered with Palunteer deeply understand the
inventory of our legacy network deeply understand
the workflows that our technicians have to and
the activities they have to do to transform that
piece but also using the ontology be able to
understand which order of operations we can go
through to transform our network and transform our
business. And so it was a very very deep exercise
um across all the data silos, across all of the
workflows, across all of the acquisitions we've
made to be able to pull this together. And
so using the AI part of AIP, we were able to
then have that operational optimization and be
able to predict the cost takeout and equipment
takeout that we could do over time and set our
goals as a company for that transformation.
Additionally, as you can see from from just how
some of the data is organized, really what becomes
critical for us in this journey is transform
the architecture, transform the experience,
transform how our customers are connecting
while we're still flying the airplane. And
so that is a is a really big issue when you
have to deliver things like 911 and also all
the critical data that enterprises like in this
room uh need to run their business. And so this
has been incredibly successful for us. But to
transform our product offerings and our enterprise
customers to be relevant to the AI economy, we
had to link inventory to systems to buildings.
But then also to what products have they
been have they consumed from us? What is that
era of what is that era of product? What is
the new product that we would like to bring
to market? How much money is that going to
actually save the company by transforming?
What's the revenue risk and revenue retention
issues that we have around that? But then also
are they able to use the digital experience? Are
they getting the speeds that they need? And how
are we going to deliver that? So we were able to
dissect down into the workflow and into our fiber
and into our copper the capabilities of that
inventory as we went. And so as we as we step
forward really what we're taking a look at is how
we automate these workflows. And that's it's it's
fully automated now for us to be able to dispatch
technicians to be able to do this and to be able
to have them move the customer with zero packet
loss. But additionally, as we step forward, we
can have the testing of the automation of the live
circuit brought back into that automation flow. As
we take a look at the next example, this is the
one at how we've taken our physical inventory,
matched the product inventory to customers, and
created a migration path for our customers and
for our portfolio. of how fast we can move from
traditional things like VPNs over traditional
uh dedicated private lines and T1s and these are
some typical telecommunications products to one in
which we can create that fabric that is necessary
to access 36 different data sources and to move
along that product journey. So Palunteer has been
on both of these steps. one on understanding our
network, two understanding our customers and three
setting up our transformation journey that we can
take our customers through and make sure that um
they can take advantage of the other part of our
business that backbone business which is building
connectivity into the major AI data centers and
hyperscalers. And so for for a telecommunications
company and a service provider, the most complex
thing we can do is to change is change the way it
was always done. Telecom's been around forever.
Service providers been around for a very long
time. and changing the foundation of our revenue
source into the new model that we want to work
towards and the new model that's being demanded
from the market required extreme precision,
extreme depth into our data and the Palunteer AI
platform has fundamentally helped us achieve those
goals. So, thank you very much. [Applause] [Music]